professor adam finn from the university
of bristol sits on the jcbi that's the
government's advisory group on vaccines
who joins us now
um it feels as if the vaccine is in a
race
against the new variant of the virus
who's winning the race right now
uh well i think that's a good analogy
we're in a race against time
and that explains uh the way the
vaccine's being deployed
it's really too soon for the vaccine to
have started having a measurable
impact but we can predict that already
it's present
it's preventing cases just simply from
the numbers
of people who've received the vaccine
which is now approaching one and a half
million people
and the rate of infection that's
occurring which is really very high now
so there are certainly thousands of
people already who have not been
admitted to hospital and who will not be
dying of this infection as a consequence
of the program that's begun in december
and matt hancock was saying that the
delays if you like to getting the
vaccine rolled out even more quickly is
about
supply i just wonder if that's your
understanding why can't we get out more
quickly is it supply
is it bureaucracy is it the actual roll
out with gps what is it
well i have to confess i'm not very
close to the organization of the
operation
so i i know about this as much as you in
terms of what's reported in the media
in terms of what's going on locally in
bristol we're certainly now receiving
supplies of vaccine
and seeing increasing numbers of people
receiving those
doses and i i understand that
getting an operation on this scale going
does take a certain amount of time but
it's
it seems to be ramping up very quickly
as far as i can
establish uh yes does certainly start to
seem to be starting to increase and the
house secretary also said that they hope
to start to be able to lift
restrictions by spring do you think
that's realistic
well i think the the strategy that we've
advised the government to take which is
to
immunise people who are at the highest
risk of becoming sick
with the infection as well as frontline
healthcare workers who are responsible
for caring for them to increase
resilience of the nhs should
result in less pressure if you like
to shut things down simply because the
primary driver of the shutdown at the
moment is the pressure on the nhs
and the concerns that we could be
confronting a situation where
sick people who can be effectively
treated and not
able to be treated for lack of people
and resources to do that
so i do think that we will see an impact
on
those pressures but i think he was
correct
in pointing out that immunizing these
people will not
stop the circulation of the virus which
is going on throughout
the population so there will continue to
be concerns about that beyond this first
phase
um you're saying about the lift that you
do think there is going to be an impact
on reducing the pressure on the nhs
and so on and but when do you think this
is going to
start to happen i mean how many people
will we have to vaccinate for that to
happen and when do you think we might
hit that number
well it'll be a progressive thing as i
said at the beginning
i think it's already happening to an
extent but of course it's happening in
the context of an epidemic that's going
up
so we might be seeing a slight reduction
in the number of cases but they're still
going up
what we should see if all goes to plan
is that that will
as well it'll play a part in reducing
that rate of rise and eventually
help bring it down but it is quite
difficult to predict exactly how soon
that will happen
because it's not just the vaccine that's
influencing the number of cases
it's also people's behavior their number
of contacts and the infectiousness of
this
new variant so very tricky to predict
that with very uh
with very much certainty at this point
but as each week goes by
we'll be able to predict it with
increasing confidence
so i suspect if you brought me on this
program in a month i could answer that
question more accurately than i can now
okay we'll we'll hold you to that we'll
we'll bring you on in a month and we'll
see
how we're getting on at that stage
definitely and you talked about
compliance
how worried are you that people are not
following the rules and what kind of
thing do you think they might be doing
to break them
uh well again this is not something that
i'm that close to
i mean i can observe what's going on
around me here in bristol
and certainly there are a lot of people
out and about walking and
you can see behind me i'm on the harbour
side here it's a very popular place for
people to come out
and spend time so my personal impression
is that
people are perhaps not being so careful
as they might be to keep well apart at
the moment which is
a very imperative need but
on the other hand this latest lockdown
has only just
uh started so the impact of the lockdown
would be expected to be seen in another
week's time
okay um now there's lots of questions
about
uh the recommendations jcbi has given
not least on the spacing of the doses
because you're saying
that the second dose can be delayed for
up to 12 weeks now pfizer
of course the makers of one of the
vaccines has said there are no data to
demonstrate that protection after the
first dose
is sustained after 21 days
i mean do you not think you need a bit
more evidence than just thinking well
the other vaccines seem to work okay
after uh
12 weeks so let's take the fisa one does
too
uh yeah i think in normal times you
would absolutely
wait for more evidence and we're busy
collecting that evidence
already as you can imagine because there
are plenty of people
now who've had one dose and we can
observe their immune responses
and the effectiveness over the coming
couple of months
but this is not normal times and
we what we have to do is extrapolate
from the data we've got
based on the knowledge that we have of
many other vaccines and the human immune
response
and make a strategic judgment because
the truth is that if you
take a vaccine dose that you're
otherwise saving to give to somebody as
a second booster dose
and put it into the arm of someone who's
not immunized at all
you will start to induce protection in
that second person
and with this rapidly rising epidemic at
the moment that is the imperative need
uh essentially if your house is on fire
you've got two fire extinguishers you
use them both
uh and you rely on there being another
fire extinguisher to obtain ready for
the next fire
you don't wait and plan in the way that
you would
uh when you're not in the middle of a
crisis
is that i completely understand the
balance of risk here
and the need to get things out quickly
particularly in the face of this new
variant
but is there a risk though that the
fires of vaccine could be
less effective if spaced out to this
amount
well we know that the uh the
effectiveness between the first and the
second dose is actually extraordinarily
high
it's one of the few bits of good luck
we've had in
recent times that these early vaccines
are
really very very effective and therefore
it's very implausible that that just
that protection would would
kind of go off a cliff would suddenly
disappear over the subsequent few weeks
we simply don't see that in other
vaccines and other diseases
and although the two different vaccines
have a different means
of of working they're basically both
resulting in expression of the spike
protein
and inducing the same immune response so
there is
actually plenty of logic to
extrapolating from one to the other
particularly
weighing up as you you clearly
understand that the risks
against the benefits which are
absolutely concrete we
we know that by giving this vaccine to
people rather than keeping it in the
freezer
it's inducing a benefit straight away
there's also a lot of concern um about
some of the new variants
and the impact this could have on the
vaccine particularly the
variant we're calling the south africa
variant and
what does the evidence suggest we know
of course that fires have said that they
believe that their vaccine will be
uh effective against the south african
africa variant
do we know anything about the oxford
astrozenica vaccine as well
well this evidence is just starting to
arrive and there's there's
one particular mutation in both variants
which is in the part of the spike
protein which binds
to human cells which was a particular
concern
and we received the evidence yesterday
from
pfizer that a virus with that particular
mutation on its own
does not reduce it does not escape if
you like from the immunity induced by
their vaccine
so as far as it goes that's a very
encouraging first step
and i think we will see over the coming
week or
the next few days more evidence on these
two variants
hopefully confirming that so so far so
good
uh i think we all think that the
vaccines will continue to work
and we all they were shown in the trials
uh but
uh we we're not quite 100 certain of
that yet
fingers crossed um talking about the
variants of course the uk scientists
picked up
the variant in kent we've got excellent
sequencing
in this country south africa picked up
on the variant emerging in their country
and we know
of course that they've got a very good
modelling program there too because of
the history
with hiv are you worried that there
could be
other serious variants in other
countries that we just simply don't know
about yet
well i think we know that this virus
varies and it was already varying
before these two particular variants
were described
and that's going to continue to happen i
think it would be better if other
countries had more
resources to do the genotyping and it
may well be that
these variants are circulating more
widely than we know about simply because
people have not been able to look but
looking forwards i think we have to
anticipate the likelihood actually that
there will be further variation
and that in due course we'll have to
modify the vaccines to sort of keep up
with the virus
that that's pretty much an expectation
but it's something that we can do
and the more people are able to monitor
the variations going on around the world
the more quickly we'll be able to do
that yeah it's quite interesting to hear
matt hancock say earlier in the program
that people could expect to get the flu
vaccine and the covert vaccine
you need for the foreseeable future to
protect them as things uh
mutate um just finally the jcvi has
recommended that
the most vulnerable uh get priority to
the vaccine first which of course
everyone can understand that's the most
likely to bring down
the death rate as quickly as possible is
there an argument though
that some key workers should be
prioritized i'm thinking particularly of
teachers to get schools reopened yeah
yeah as a pediatrician i'm
extremely keen that we can try and
reopen schools and then keep them open
um and absolutely that's the next phase
of
the program and jcvi will be discussing
over the coming months
uh phase two if you like as to who
should be prioritized
now these considerations start to be
uh social values in a way more than the
criteria we normally use which is
pressure on the health service
there are broader considerations when it
comes to people with different
occupations and the relative importance
of them in society but
i would certainly be a strong advocate
for schools and teachers
so you think that jc jcvi could
recommend that teachers get moved up the
queue then
quite soon well i i i can't predict
exactly what will be prioritized but i
can say that we will be
discussing this and coming up with a
plan and i can also say that
when it comes to teachers i think we all
appreciate the critical role that they
all play
and so that really will figure in the
discussions and when one of those
discussions happening
uh well we're meeting next thursday
we're meeting every week at the moment
and uh our chair has uh instructed us
that we
we must come up with a a phase two plan
by the middle of february
uh really interesting to talk thank you
very much for letting us know that'd be
welcome news to
some teachers i can imagine as well
thank you for being on
pleasure nice to talk